la Garde côtière confirme ce que
plusieurs redoutaient cinq pièces
majeures du sous-marin ont été retrouvés
à 500 mètres de l'épave du Titanic
le premier débris était le Coran en
dehors du compartiment de pression puis
un champ de débris les pièces retrouvées
portent à croire que le sous-marin a
imposé avant que les équipes n'arrivent
pour les recherches
étaient sous l'eau et n'ont rien entendu
laissant entendre une panne
catastrophique
à de telles profondeurs la pression de
l'eau est énorme cette matière exerce
une pression sur le
moindre petit brille la moindre petite
faille c'est la rupture de l'équilibre
justement et la coque seront et c'est
terminé en quelques minutes
16 ans paulajolais le propriétaire
d'ochengate stocktonerach le Britannique
a mis l'homme d'affaires chez Ada Daoud
et son fils Souleymane
pour les proches qui comptaient les
heures comme la fille de paul-hen
argelet la tente est désormais terminée
mon père a participé à la première
expédition qui a eu son Titanic à la fin
des années 80 et depuis c'est sa plus
grande passion et dans tous les cas lui
lui il est il est heureux là oui tous
les regards étaient rivés sur
l'opération de recherche et sauvetage
depuis 4 jours la zone de recherche
s'étendait sur 26000 km2 avec une
dizaine de navires et de l'équipement
spécialisés mais nombreuses questions
demeurent concernant la sécurité du
sous-marin et sur les mesures à prendre
pour éviter une autre catastrophe de la
sorte ici marie-abelle rochamp
Radio-Canada Montréal